reading this mother makes most boringest
movie ever for future spoiled child uh
here's Katie again the movie wants to
tell this story parallel to the first
paranormal activity only it strange that
Katie never once mentions what's
happening to her sister and new family
or anything in the first one
[Music]
foreshadowing oh that baby turning into
a one-year-old escalated quickly
I just I got tired of recording things
around the house part two the quickening
he's brutally tired from being annoying
touched demon fuck's up the whole house
except the nursery because when you're
about to kidnap a child you need to show
respect for his or her living quarters
here's where the movies best idea gets
wasted cameras are everywhere but only a
couple of them will actually capture
anything worthwhile in this movie even
the slightest glimpse of something from
some of these worthless cameras would
make it worthwhile but as you will soon
see you will be desperately trying to
find entertainment where none exists
some people think that's a demon being
scary not me I think the demon is
misunderstood that's just the demon
being hilarious the Spanish nanny knows
the place is haunted cliche my
daughter's screaming better run to
wherever she is carrying my camera
there's a statue a lot of uh-huh because
she's Spanish right that's racist
[Music]
where's your two-year-old oh dude
chronicling of everything will not
include this smashing dude release the
crank and penis jokes are not only
terrible they're also super passe good
job being super passe for some reason
and katie is the one to wake up and
comfort the baby not either of the
baby's parents movie waits 14 minutes to
tell you what the prequel and not a
sequel which if I'm honest white doing a
good dozen or so sins that I'd written
already it wasn't until the first
Paranormal Activity was released that
these assholes discovered they had
freaky found footage that actually
predated that movie's footage I don't
know I we don't want to reveal anything
that would spoil the surprises of
paranormal activity 3 this footage was
filmed before the first movies events so
how did the powers-that-be who found the
footage dean Katie and Mike a story more
worthy
being the first one told then this
footage why don't you just admit you're
capitalizing on this real family's pain
by turning out sequels to their grisly
murders this franchise is like the
where's waldo of horror movies tons of
harmless security footage designed to
make you hunt and pet for any wisp of
movement or ghost activity Waldo I don't
know why this family needs a nanny the
mom doesn't appear to work and why would
she her husband owns a ton of Burger
Kings what does she do that she needs a
nanny to help out with the kid movie
cuts to black to emphasize the
nothingness
now this pool cleaner thing was out last
night on night 2 these people just never
swim and leave the pool cleaner bond
24/7
how did that get since yesterday no he
repeats the exact same sequence from
earlier of various security cameras
capturing nothing because repetition
equals pot this pool doesn't have dozens
of dead cartel members who wronged
Gustavo Fring floating in it here we go
again these people are horrible parents
to both dogs and humans 32 seconds of
nothing happening in the kids room
except for some noises you have to be
wearing headphones to even hear we've
done a lot of these demon movies I
wonder what these assholes do when
they're planning to steal kids or
possess people they show up they knock
some things around and then they get
tired that's some sort of process they
have to go through before they can
accomplish their goals you have to be
really patient when you're a
bloodthirsty demon from the lower bowels
of hell movie is really trying my
patience with this sickening thud is the
sound of fury signifying nothing wait
why didn't we get to see this camera's
view point during the loud noise you
clearly had this angle before and after
it so if people stitching together this
fountain footage left that out for some
reason than they are manipulative dicks
and I can no longer trust this movie
dicks didn't she already pray away the
bad spirits if that didn't work earlier
why does she think it's going to now
does she really mean it this time
Martine is now getting fired for burning
incense and whatever fire whoever you
like she's not an important person but
why can't she somehow communicate to
Daniel and Christy to look at the
security tapes and at least see that
something weird is happening at the
house I guess this kid can see whatever
demonic force is in the house it's
probably playing peek-a-boo with him or
doing the magic thumb trick I would
never accuse a father of getting all
Paris Hilton sex tape with his daughter
but this father is getting all Paris
Hilton sex tape with his daughter
cleanest pool ever
when we ever see the kids room when
whatever makes him cry habits in the
first movie even though the demons
actions didn't make any sense at least
we saw something this movie is all about
going out of its way to not show you
anything sounds can be scary sure but
when there are six cameras throughout
the house that capture neither jack nor
she it's frustrating as hell let this be
a lesson to all you new parents every
time your baby cries its might be a
demon we find out later that was a bird
why just this one bird and not all the
birds why does the dumbest bird have the
keenest demon detection don't worry
that's just the demon pretending to be a
truck driver playing on a CB radio but
much like stealing kids are possessing
Katie it takes a long time for a demon
to get a commercial driver's license so
fantasy will have to do until death 32
minutes in legitimately considering
bailing on this sins video and letting
Chris finish the rest on his own this
fucking repetitive bullshit man
demon is careless with cook wick demon
is careless with cook quick whoa this
contraption was found outside the pool
after you put it inside the pool and
you're just amused by that it is clear
evidence of an intruder and foul play
man what the fuck I'm definitely and
that's the origin story of Mekas
obsession with cameras what stuff demon
hunting backstory is obscured by
cleavage what's your take on this whole
ghost situation poor movie is so clearly
conditioning you that you probably
aren't anywhere near as mad about this
as I am
demon arson of course ali's having a
romantic hot tub rendezvous with her
boyfriend when this happens so that the
dad has someone to blame this stupid she
married couple bicker about the pot
falling incident instead of the fire
started while your daughter was in the
hot tub with some boy incident which
honestly is fucked up get your
priorities straight people this is
something you didn't know the paranormal
phenomena I hate it when you have a
clean pool I just had to go to the
bathroom and honestly I didn't even
pause the movie and yet somehow I missed
nothing what is it about the hours of
3:00 a.m. that make this demon come out
this motherfucker is leaving the bar way
too late it's time to impose a curfew
seance you'd better take a look at this
cliche you know we can't just let this
affect us that much if we do that the
terrorists won this is still funny even
in 2006 also why is this dickhead still
shooting video of random nonsense like
this
prankster demon continues his wacky
antics because one day he'll have a
youtube channel everyone can enjoy demon
diversify zits scare portfolio by using
Shadow Puppets ah felt like a shadow of
creeping on me teenage daughter going to
bed thinks nothing of the wide-open
front door movie is a dip to
storytelling even realizes it left the
oven on back in hell and decides to quit
baby snatching for the night these
parents are so loving they don't even
put child protective installations on
their basement doorknobs the six minutes
cut out of this security footage you're
not important at all how did this
asshole get back in the crib good the
demon come back and lift him back in
what kind of depth demon is this earlier
when you wanted to see what the hell is
going on with the pool cleaner you
consulted your expensive security system
now with video proof of all sorts of you
decide to play asshole dad and are not
the least bit curious about what
happened at all that it's probably not a
ghost it's probably something else and
it's possibly being a character goes and
does research that has all the answers
for the weird happening cliche they have
a keen sense of humor despite being a
hundred percent even I mean he got you
good with that locking you out of house
thing a minute ago well follow the
defaulter and his or her brood until its
soul of an infant is collected ah the
Internet the cause of and solution to
all of life's problems
finally the curious girl consults the
security footage also footages the
widescreen edition complete with the
black bars at the top and bottom of the
screen which are normal I'm sure it's
happened to you a million times got you
completely locked out of the house and
everything do i that also curious girl
decides not to look at any of the other
footage all that night basically
considering the door closing is the only
footage worthy of your view night 17 I
gave up carrying on night 2 FY on so
naturally my first move was to turn on a
video camera girl who hears a noise like
this upon turning a doorknob continues
with her plan to open said door horror
vlogging family German Shepherd nowhere
to be found during this particular
strange noises in the house scene demon
risks waking up the entire house by
plane will because this guy's deal
little I think it's starting again I
don't want to talk about this Christy at
least not until the next movie which
will actually be the first movie but
what I'm only here for a paycheck this
is good personal to get on camera right
now so ignore the creepy and it goes
away good advice
also you basically completely ignore
this advice when the creepy starts
happening to you actually you ignore
this whole entire story in the first
movie probably just the wind
also just forget about it and I'm sure
it will never happen again no need to
show anybody this footage because Katie
said to leave it alone family does not
immediately move out right the now
[Music]
seeing punctuating teapots what if
Christy's Creek my mother made a deal
with the demon so she could get rich and
Hunter is the first male to be born on
Christy side since at least the 1930s
okay you want me to believe that since
the great-grandmother all the kids born
on that side were female fine that's
possible but unlikely but how does that
person making the bargain actually give
up anything when it waits until the
great-grandchildren have a son that
means great-grandmother made a bargain
and never had to pay for don't tell me
that there's a coincidence
clearly you mean don't tell me that she
is coincidence the same is for no one in
the crew or editing department noticing
your mistake night 19 the natives have
accepted me as one of their own they
show no desire whatsoever to try and
escape my hauntings operation become a
human proceeding as planned good god
what an asshole this guy is when the
first movie did this speed-up trick we
saw some pretty fucked-up stuff like
Katie just standing and watching mica
for five hours or something like that
here it's just sped up footage like the
director is satisfying our subconscious
need to fast-forward this dog is
struggling with something basically off
camera that is surely getting picked up
by another camera but hey whoever found
this footage decided to turn it into a
horror movie
rather than a documentary and what with
a less-is-more at it serious girl who's
been waking up to investigate noises
only wakes up when the dog attack is
long over dad and daughter play right
into the demons hands by taking the dog
at a late-night emergency vet clinic and
leaving mom and baby home alone for
optimal torturing this woman who knows
her house is haunted has left her baby
alone for nearly an hour just ignore it
movie captures an amazing footage of
what it's like to be locked in the
basement with a demon for over an hour
whatever happened after Christy came
around the corner like someone
demon-possessed was not important enough
to put in this movie this child is
crying because his mother did a full
reenactment of the Blair Witch Project
amazingly he was able to get through 20
minutes of Christie pretending to be all
three characters during the map arguing
scene dad is pacing back and forth
trying to figure out how to blame the
wind for this sure olive oil on a cross
probably won't work but not with that
attitude it won't well thank God the
housekeeper is super well versed in evil
spirits and she's like a convenience
keeper movie wants me to feel some kind
of conflicted about this decision to
pass the demon from Christy to her
sister thus creating the first movie and
honestly I can't fault them if my
Hispanic housekeeper rub something in
some olive oil and said this was my only
option I definitely sell out the sister
in a heartbeat
I mean right so could this demon just
not have already taken the kid by now or
did it have to wait all the way to this
very moment to finally make its move I
feel like demon Christy should already
be on the road by now
the kid to wherever firstborn sons go to
be collected by demons pawnshop I'm
guessing pawnshop even stash the kid in
the basement for safekeeping I guess now
the dad is filming this why they're
gonna tell me so that he can see through
the cameras night vision to which I'm
gonna respond 89% of average American
homes have 2.3 flashlights on hand I
understand that they're passing the
demon onto Katie but why do they think
that the demon will stop wanting the kid
Ali already researched this and it's
pretty clear what it wants so this is
like the robbing Peter to pay Paul of
demon management you probably should
just ignore it
Paranormal Activity to meet paranormal
activity I know it's a weird time warper
going through here where the two comes
before the one it then took demon
possessed Katie an entire day to travel
from San Diego to Carlsbad I'm guessing
she went to Solana Beach to soak up the
Sun and tell everyone to lighten up then
she went to go steal a kid
[Music]
ruby's product placements include actual
advertisements including two for dunkin
donuts hey did she come all the way here
in a blood-soaked shirt
the distance between San Diego and
Carlsbad is about 35 miles there's some
extremely unobserved people between
those cities Katie will not waste 30
seconds of time while the series of
security monitors updates us on the
status of the staircase nursery front
door Poole and Daniel's neck the kid
survives this so let me ask you
something movie if in the first
paranormal activity you knew Micah's
body was found on October 11th how did
you not know about Katie's further
excursion to snap up her sister's
firstborn did someone have to give you
found footage before you connected the
dots I'm just giving you movie I know
you didn't have any clue what would
happen in Paranormal Activity to when
you did the first one
[Music]
you